Good morning John!
oh yeah yeah look at
that tire
That one's pretty squishy.
Is it okay to
touch random people's bikes?
You want to hear a funny story?
I left my computer on an airplane
so I'm having other people
edit this vlog for me.
Here's the plan:  I put this footage
on the Internet. People on the
internet then take that footage
everybody makes their own video with it
and then we vote on which one goes on
the vlogbrothers channel and we do this all
within like 24 hours.
So amsterdam things I need
I need to find. I need to
see like rowhouse, bicyclers
which shouldn't be hard,
a canal.
I found bicyclers.
(music) Sometimes the world looks perfect.
nothing to rearrange
sometimes you
just get a feeling
like you need some kind of change
(Hank talking)
This is a questionable strategy I've made
which is to just to start walking and
see if I find something good.
I am immediately lost.
This city is not on a grid
and also my phone doesn't a hundred
percent work like I can call and text
but it cannot use maps. There's no data.
So to get real honest, I'm gonna have to work
it out the old-fashioned way
uhh, which I have
completely forgotten how to do.
I mean even the littering is neat.
They just left it there, right side up.
What is a "chocomouth"? It smells like chocolate
Is it like "Yoo-hoo"?  I was going to
read the label but it's all in Dutch.
Sometimes you see things on the
ground you don't know what they are and
Have to find out.
Oh! It's like a little light,
the tiniest, cheapest bike light
you could possibly imagine.
You know. I'm keeping it.
I mean...
presented without comment.
Hey Pigeon, there's a whole tortilla
like on a windowsill right over there.
Whole tortilla. You could feed your entire
family for a month.
A whole tortilla.
Stop walking away from me! I'm trying to help!
Found row houses
with the little hooks that they used to get stuff up
because you can't carry 'em up
cuz they're too skinny.
All that's left is a canal.
I have to find a canal
I just saw a fourth Amsterdam thing:
2 people just smoked pot on the street,
which of course is normal here. I think this is a
wedding cake made out of diapers.
That's...I... you... yep, yep
I definitely am going the wrong direction.
But wait, but just ahead of the
highway, just in front of it
I think... What is it?
It's a canal. It's a big one!
Ooo a moorhen! Can you see it?
Oh, it just disappeared. Bye, Moorhen!
Come back! I'm making a video.
Hello? It was like 'I don't...
we don't like to be on vid-'  There it is. Hey!
John, the Dutch people think that I'm weird
but that's okay.
I think the dutch people are weird.
You know this might not be a canal.
This might be a river.
It might be the river Amstel, I feel like,
Maybe. Maybe not. I don't know!
I have come to the definitive conclusion that I'm
not in the canal-y part of Amsterdam.
ok, John, I'm 90% sure this is the
same canal I was at before.
But I am now a hundred percent sure
that it is, in fact, a canal.
Which means I found all the
things that I was looking for.
So now I have to try and find my
way back to where I was.
I don't even know what my hotel looks like.
This is the street where they keep all
the cars in Amsterdam.
Every single Amsterdam car
is here right now.
The pigeon didn't listen to me.
I see these bikes and- I just- I think
many of them must have just been here
for centuries
I feel like they're
intentionally leaving old bikes just so
it looks like there are a lot of bikers.
It's gotta be a lot of these bikes not in use.
Like this. This one!
This is just still here right?
like somebody
has left it there.
or do they? Yeah, yeah, look at that tire
I'm very glad to finally be in this city
which I've wanted to go to for a long time,
and to be here for VidCon Europe
which is going to be a ball.
I would like to thank
this person
for editing this video.
There's a lot of other versions,
hopefully, of this video,
edited by other people.
I encourage you, John,
and also
anyone else to go look at those videos.
Thanks to all the people who helped me with this.
Thanks John.
And I'll see you on Tuesday.
(stranger in car) bye.
(Hank) bye!